I was reading when doing a parasite cleanse, lots of heavy metals are released into the system.
Are they the tissue or the blood?
I don't know if...
I don't know how true that is or not.
The truth is that everybody has heavy metals in your tissues,
and the most common cell type that is going to harbor toxins, chemicals,
poisons, drugs, heavy metals are fat cells.
I've always said that fat cells have the gift of accommodation.
They like, welcome everybody in.
Come on in, stay here.
We have an extra room for you.
We'll make supper and breakfast with muffins in the morning.
That's what fat cells do.
They're wonderful human beings.
And they allow everybody in no matter how bad your past is.
So, I don't know that doing a parasite cleanse draws heavy metals or chemicals out.
I don't know that to be true.
If you end up with more circulating heavy metals,
remember they're going to be in the tissues, they'll be in the cells.
You will have some in the spaces between the cells that's called the extracellular space,
but it typically won't stay there.
Your limb system is always attempting to clear that away.
You get anything that goes into your limb system will eventually get to your leadus system,
circulates through your liver, hopefully exits the bloodstream at the liver,
and then gets deposited into the bile after going through phase one and phase two detoxification in the liver.
And in the bile, it goes down to the gallbladder and from the gallbladder,
do you want them first part of the small intestine?
And from there, hopefully, will be deposited in your toilet without being reabsorbed in the large intestine.
That's why you would use binders.
So, with any detoxification or even a parasite kill type program,
you want to go slow because you could overwhelm your liver,
and to circulate these things somewhere else, you could overwhelm your gallbladder.
That is the major cause of stone formation and gallbladder sluggishness.
And then you could, if your bowel movements aren't regular and healthy,
you could just be reabsorbing these things.